we have a lot of strategies and they're
different for Iraq and Afghanistan we we
maybe I should I'll talk about Iraq
first and then Afghanistan in in the
case of Iraq we have been working very
hard with displaced people inside Iraq
and also with refugees Iraqi refugees in
Syria and Jordan and those people have
all been uprooted from their homes just
to quantify it there at least 2 million
uprooted people inside Iraq and another
close to two million in Syria and Jordan
and then smaller numbers in other
surrounding countries those people we've
gone and talked with them interview them
there's no question the ones outside of
Iraq do not feel it is safe to return
once it's safe for them to return that
will be the best outcome and we can hope
that happens soon but right now there
are few the few that have gone back to
check the situation out discovered that
their homes are now occupied by others
they could not return to their home base
they would have to go to other
communities that were religious and
ethnic ties were closer and as a result
they see no prospect at the moment for
going back the same is true for those
uprooted was in Iraq there there has
been a movement of people from
relatively heterogeneous places to more
homogeneous places and there's not
likelihood that that's going to change
and that means people who have lost
their homes are not really in a position
to get them back so the the crisis in
Iraq as far as refugees and internally
displaced people is concerned still has
a long way to go before its resolution
we have advocated that in larger number
of Iraqis especially those who have
worked with the US government in Iraq be
fast tracks for resettlement in the
United States and that slowly is
beginning to happen there's only been as
I say out of the roughly 4 million of
Iraqis who have been uprooted from their
homes very a very small fraction of
initially a thousand or 1,500 finally
went up to 10,000 now it's up to 15
in the year but the total Iraqi
population that's been resettled at the
US is miniscule compared to the overall
need and that will continue to be the
case even if we aggressively increase
the number of Iraqis admitted there's no
way that any significant fraction of the
four million uprooted people will be
resettle to United States we should do
more there but that's not going to solve
the problem we also have to provide
support to Syria and Jordan not we the
United States the international
community as a whole because it they
have assumed an enormous burden and
taking care of the Iraqis who have
landed on their in their backyard and
Syria in particular has been extremely
generous to Iraqis that will allow them
to go to their schools they've made
health care available but this is a
relatively poor country and needs to
have more international assistance and
it's received so far until it's safe for
the Iraqi refugees to return home which
will be the best outcome for everybody
when that happens but it hasn't happened
yet
Afghanistan yeah the International
Rescue Committee has been involved with
Afghan refugees since 1980 since the
Soviet invasion we've worked with Afghan
refugees in Peshawar Pakistan and other
parts of Pakistan on the border with
Afghanistan we have conducted health
clinics and school programs there that
really have made it possible for these
Afghan refugees that develop the
capacities that will allow them to
return home and a great many have
returned home at the height there were
as many as seven or even eight million
refugees mostly in Pakistan and Iran and
all but a million and a half worm at the
most two million have now returned back
to Afghanistan we've also been involved
on the Afghan side of the border since
since about nineteen eighty eight so for
20 years and there we've worked with
Afghans as they return to help them get
back on their feet so they can take care
of themselves and that's it's been
exhilarating to watch that process I
when I go to Afghanistan it just it
really gives me great pleasure to visit
for example nurseries where we gave the
saplings that first were planted 20
years ago and now they're growing the
poplars that become the ceiling beams in
their mud-brick homes we have the
teachers the girls whom we educated in
schools in Peshawar have now returned
and we've managed to get the credential
they received in as refugees recognized
by the Afghan Ministry of Education so
they are able to teach within Afghan
schools in fact the curriculum that we
developed in the shower is now that the
the accepted model for the dari speaking
curriculum in Afghanistan so we feel as
if we really had our long-term
engagement with Afghans has been very
important for helping them get bit back
on their feet
it's called the the national solidarity
program and we have we were really
central to its development in a number
of ways the the man who was the minister
of rural development at the time this
program was implemented now eight seven
eight years ago the man named haneef
ottmar who had been the head of our
programs in our seas programs in
Afghanistan before he joined the
government of Hamid Karzai as the
minister of rural development and he
knew that we had a program the really
the prototype of what is called the
national solidarity program we'd had it
in in Rwanda and so he had a team of
rwandans come and work with Afghans in
designing this program and here's the
way it works we establish local village
councils at the village level we're now
involved in over a thousand villages in
Afghanistan and those village councils
decide what their highest priority is
for development usually it's a a water
system or a school or a bridge that
connects two villages that otherwise in
the rainy season aren't able to be
connected with each other but but the
village council itself makes a selection
and then the money comes it was
originally world bank funding but it
comes through the Ministry of Rural
Development to that local village and
it's just tremendously exciting to see
the projects that these villagers
identified and the ownership that they
feel because they not only identified
them they often contribute labor the
maximum grant that they can get from the
world bank funding is is sixty thousand
dollars and many of these are really
quite ambitious projects but they
contribute labor and local materials and
are extremely pleased and proud of what
they've created when they're done we are
now in over a thousand villages our
staff for this program is a hundred
percent Afghan it was initially had a
small cadre of international staff but
we have trained and brought along
Afghans who are now the leaders when I
go and visit and see some of these
programs I go with our Afghan staff and
and witness their pride in these in
these programs and the way they are
respected and esteemed by the local
villagers and our staff is drawn from a
variety of different backgrounds many of
whom were in different factions of the
Mujahideen who fought the Soviets and
decided well it's now time to build
rather than continue fighting so there
there are people who really have a stake
in the future Afghanistan of Afghanistan
and can make a big difference in the
long term resistance of especially rural
Afghanistan to the Taliban now my hope
is that the new designs that the Obama
administration is developing will
reinforce that kind of decentralized
effort that builds capacity at the local
level as the counterpart to having an
Afghan government that is in Kabul but
that will never given the history of
Afghanistan control all of Afghanistan
it's really crucial that they're also be
a presence that is positive and and and
connected to the central government but
has a good deal of autonomy and the
national solidarity program is really
the model for that
you